so many people are jumping on the Barack
Obama bandwagon which as an African
American really offends me if there is a
God why did he make me an atheist I like
an escalator man cause the escalator
could never break it can only become
stairs till it floats it to me
Asia Timmy said other young boy was your
mother very strict with you I said let
me make one thing absolutely clear my
mother was never young boy you're
looking at a very proud Canadian who's
very proud of the education system in
Canadia I think
I think it's the goodest of all 17
countries the US military are pulling
out of Baghdad fair enough withdrawing
is what you do after you [ __ ] something
I remember the day the candle shop
burned down everybody just stood around
and saying happy birthday when I was in
America I already got into the culture I
went into his shop and the guy said have
a nice day and it didn't so I sued him
well the kid my fairy godmother asked me
if I wanted a long penis for your long
memory I I forget my response
I don't have a girlfriend I just know a
girl who would get really mad if she
heard me say that gold-plated chains
would make a nice retirement gift
for a very very good slave you got a lot
of nerve showing your face around your
house er look who's talking do you mind
if I masturbate like most Canadians I
like to go clubbing but if there's no
seals around
so I was in this Airport and I said to
this woman I said oh she said no sir
this is the check-in desk I love Jesus
it was my superhero I like my border
security like I like my sex sure I have
boundaries but occasionally I let a
Mexican man sneak in was that casino
stand by the door a security guy came
over he said you're gonna have to move
you're blocking the fire exit
so if there was a fire I wasn't gonna
run my uncle was a clown for Ringling
Brothers Circus and when he died all his
friends went to the funeral in one car
my proctologist used to be a
photographer yeah he took x-rays told me
to bend over and say cheese
oh no I was horrible in school I failed
math so many times I can't even cats I
was good at history No
no I was if you want to know what the
world would be like in a
post-apocalyptic future for four pounds
national Express can get you to Glasgow
my sister your husband live next to a
bunch of cell phone towers and their
concern is can affect the health of
their children you know if they can stop
having miscarriages so watch the
football match in Japan at the end they
start doing martial arts I said man I
said what's going on he said there's two
minutes of min jury time
I quit my job at the helium gas Factory
I refused to be spoken to in that tone
my friend asked me if you could have any
superpower in the world what would it be
I said Cold War Russia I can't get into
the flossing thing people who smoke
cigarettes they said man you don't know
how hard it is to quit smoking yes I do
it's as high as is to start flossing a
very common male fantasy is to have two
women at the same time want to cook want
to clean just because you're offended it
doesn't mean you're right so I get off
the plane and I forgot to undo my
seatbelt and I'm pulling the plane
through the terminal now you get older
it's tough to get girls to best need to
be as bisexual then you got a shot on
everybody I preferred French over
chemistry because the chemistry teacher
and I just didn't have any
repor sadly as a kid I don't speak
French such is life this is true my my
mom actually should have been on one of
the planes that crashed on 9/11 I think
I play golf I'm not gonna go up I never
got good I never got a hole-in-one but I
did hit a guy and that's way more
satisfying it's when your working-class
mom Jesus is like an unpaid babysitter
so I get out of the bed I figure to go
for a walk she said how long I'm gonna
be gone he said the whole time we talk
here for a second that since there's no
big deal to have a woman in the White
House John F Kennedy had a thousand of
them I am okay when I was the kid I got
no respect at all you know they always
made me take the family picture and that
way I wouldn't be in it people worry
about their physical appearance we all
have silly hang-ups personally I worry
that one of my balls is bigger than the
other two
religion is enormous it is when it's
when your God starts telling you that
you should kill homosexuals
we all have bittersweet memories of our
childhood I recall one summer when the
neighborhood parents were buying their
children's skateboards it was the rage
at the time except for my parents they
told me that we were too poor and that
they couldn't afford to buy me a
skateboard but I remember one night I
tippy-toe doubt of my bedroom I got a
piece of wood and a hammer and I beat
them to death
amen every book is a children's book if
the kid can read I've spent the past two
years looking for my ex-girlfriends
killer but no one will do it if my
grandmother knew how much money I spent
on her funeral she would be spinning in
her ditch my girlfriend's family are
quite religious I remember the first
time I went to stay with her at her
parents house and her dad wouldn't let
us sleep together which was a shame
because he's very attractive a
restaurant I ordered a chicken sandwich
but I don't think the waitress
understood me because she said how would
you like your eggs so I tried to answer
her anyhow I said incubated and then
raised and then beheaded and then and
then cut up and then put onto a grill
and they put onto a bun damn it's gonna
take a while
scrambled i sit at the hotel at night I
think of something that's funny then I
go get a pen and I write it down or if
the pens too far away I had to convince
myself that what I thought of aint funny
to to commit suicide is is denying grace
of God [ __ ] off was five years old
watching TV only you can prevent forest
fires oh no every night out the window
with a bucket of water you know what man
I'm sick of following my dreams I'm just
gonna ask where they're going and hook
up with them later this farmer came up
to me he said I've got 68 sheep can you
round them up for me how's it short 70
you know you can't please all the people
all the time and last night all those
people were at my show
there are immigrants that have come to
America stolen jobs and murdered the
local population and we call those
immigrants the founding fathers oh I'm
in a sexy girl a few weeks ago working a
restaurant making hamburgers she told me
she to make a big boy in three minutes
and a boy big in two minutes
[Applause]
[Laughter]
my sexual fantasy is to make love to
Sigmund Freud's father mother
I'm a year closer to death than last
time I saw you when I was out in the
middle of the desert a UFO landed three
one inch tall guys get out they walked
over to me he said are you really one
inch tall they said no we're really very
far away and I was a very ugly kid every
time I oh man wanted sex my mother
showed her my picture you know what man
I got a parrot the parrot talked but it
did not say I'm hungry so it died I'm an
atheist I don't believe in about 2,700
God's Christian's don't believe in two
thousand six hundred and ninety-nine so
they're nearly as atheistic as moon yes
have a hobby very embarrassed about I
could tell you my hobby but then I'd
have to kill you which coincidentally is
my hobby
nobody wants to be alone a recently
divorced friend of mine is hopeful once
again finding romance beer-bellied
completely bald I don't like her chances
I like people
yeah I just know my favorite animal my
theory of evolution is that Darwin was
adopted
I got caught masturbating to a National
Geographic magazine not my finest hour I
don't know who was more embarrassed to
me or my dentist I went to a proper
showbiz party recently and Brad Pitt was
there and they say never meet your
heroes but I think Brad handled it
really well
Twitter is like being able to read every
toilet wall in the world you gotta be
careful I was involved in a one-night
stand that went horribly wrong
we've been married three years now why
did the Muslim cross the road because he
was being relocated by Israeli
authorities to make more room for Jewish
settlements on the West Bank
sweet nothing went right I bought a
waterbed there were two Cuban guys
swimming they're looking for Florida one
time a guy handed me a picture of me so
here's a picture of me when I was
younger every picture is of you when you
were younger
driving down the street passed a gas
station there are two signs in the
window Help Wanted self-service
so I went in nerd right off
I'm against picketing but I don't know
how to show it
I love everywhere in the world cuz
wherever you go people do all the same
it's not easy being green when I was a
young boy my dad said to me sit Timmy
said you can be anything you want to be
in life the sky's the limit which made
me sad because I wanted to be an
astronaut too euro from the sale of
every one of my DVDs goes to the poor
underprivileged children of Cambodia who
manufacture them my wife is beautiful my
wife has an ass like JLo no jello
I'll tell you when I was a kid I was
poor very poor how poor I was so poor my
neighborhood the rainbow is I'm black
and white you go to the grocery store
and you stand in front of lunchmeat
section for too long you start to get
pissed off at turkeys you see like
turkey ham turkey pastrami turkey
Bologna someone needs to tell the
turkeys man just be yourself
you make love to the right woman Johnny
it's beautiful beautiful I mean the last
time I made love to my wife it was
ridiculous nothing was happening I
looked right so what's the matter can't
you think of anyone either I like rice
rice is great when you're hungry and you
want to thousand of something is my wife
dissatisfied with my body a tiny part of
me says yes
I got a new CD it's in stores when you
have a CD in stores you have to do
in-store appearances if nobody shows up
I just pretend like I'm shopping no I've
got a girlfriend
I've been going out with my girlfriend
for sex
that loves bread but he doesn't have the
capability to buy a loaf I remember when
I was a fetus I used to sneak out at
night when my mother was sleeping
I don't worry about being dead I won't
know about it that's the best thing
about being dead it's like being stupid
it's only painful for others yeah Tom's
an airline pilot so if your name is Jack
cuz you walk into the cockpit the
copilot says uh Jack Neville start
screaming I gotta you know what man I
got a parrot the parrot talk but it did
not say I'm hungry
so it died I hope you guys are doing
okay money-wise I'm set for life provide
I die next Tuesday I got a new dog he's
a paranoid Retriever he brings a kever
ething cuz he's not sure what I throw he
trying to become at least most famous
person my neighbor there's a guy my
neighborhood he's in the Guinness Book
of Records he's had 43 concussions he
lives very close in fact just a stone's
throw away but the point
I used to do drugs I still do but I used
to